[Musique]
c'est la vertèbre orange
donc la côte
droite
[Musique]
oui
e
m'appelle pierre henri fontaine je suis
né en france
ya fort longtemps nous sommes ici sur
l'île une ère où je passe une retraite
extrêmement agréable
[Musique]
gère un musée qui est consacré aux
squelettes que j'appelle le musée du
squelette expliqué c'est un musée qui
est consacrée uniquement au squelette et
à son interprétation
[Musique]
j'arrive à 81 kg 84 ans révolus donc ma
vie et fait ma vie est derrière
c'est tellement fouiller dans les cada
car moment donné là je sais que je vais
devenir un cador
puis c'est dans l'homme de chevet
[Musique]
à
un but
[Musique]
depuis ma plus tendre enfance j'ai
ramassé des ce cas là et elle est
toujours toujours été intéressé par les
animaux par les squelettes depuis que
suis tout petit j'ai un père qui était
ingénieur en mécanique qui m'expliquait
beaucoup de choses j'ai eu un professeur
sciences naturelles en première année du
secondaire qui était extraordinaire
comme prof et qui nous expliquait du ski
se servait beaucoup des squelettes pour
nous pour donner les cours et nous
intéresser à la biologie et c'est lui
qui a été peut-être le facteur
déclencheur avis elle s'est partagé
entre l'enseignement et les squelettes
et j'ai couru après les eaux toute ma
vie et des gens qui rentrent dans le
musée puis qui voit tout ce qu'il ya
dans le musée puis je les vois aulas ils
s'attendent pas quand il voit le
l'espèce de hangar qui sert abriter le
musée ils s'attendent pas ce qu'il ya
dans le musée le je m'amuse temps en
temps je leur dis vous voulez faire une
usine de combien on ne refait une
demie-heure et moi je dis toi tu
resteras 2h30 là c'est certain
[Musique]
le but c'est de faire parler les skull
qu'un squelette étant donné que c'est la
charpente du corps de l'animal et
l'engin regarde la charte ans j'ai une
idée vraiment bonne de ce que l'animal
faisait de sa vue et le squelette
soutient la théorie de l'évolution parce
que dans le squelette il ya plein
vestiges pourquoi dans un bras de
baleines ya autant d'offres par exemple
c'est ridicule parce qu'un bras de
baleines sea air and communes bas ça ne
bouge qu'ici au niveau de l'épaule alors
pourquoi il ya un numerus à un radieux
sur cubitus une main avec un karpin
métacarpe et des phalanges - j'ai besoin
de tousser ou parce que mon bras est
extrêmement mobiles ben moi que si
jérôme demandé de fabriquer une baleine
qu'est ce que je ferais je mettrais un
seul os d'un bout à l'autre mais quand
une baleine à un ancêtre quadrupède et
que cet ancêtre avait dans sa pâte tous
les os qui a dans mon bras et que cet
animal évolué vers un animal qui nagent
main son bras marcheurs va évoluer vers
une nageoire mais c'est plus simple de
garder les structures et distinct que de
complètement supprimée sol
je sais pas comment exprimer cerveau
lille pour moi c'est devenu c'est devenu
une seconde nature c'est mon pays
alors voilà de gaulle alors on voit son
grand nez une bouche un peu méprisante
puis son menton et de goult
moi c'est de gaulle enfin le fait d'être
venu sur l'île verte m'a amené à
récolter des squelettes de mammifères
marins en particulier des bélougas qui
venait s'échouer sur l'île et j'ai suis
tombé amoureux de villeverte j'y suis
j'ai acheté une maison et depuis ce
temps là j'y passe le maximum de temps
[Musique]
pour le récupérer
ça c'est dégraisser
[Musique]
j'ai découvert c'est elle avec sa vie
avec ces insulaires qui pourrait être
charmant ou détestable ça dépend des si
on était amis de leur ennemi ou ami de
leurs amis ça c'était assez particulier
comme ambiance mais c'était quand même
des gens qui étaient qui rend des
services il y avait une espèce de
solidarité parce que sur une île on est
obligé de s'aider les uns les autres
parce qu'on a pas le choix c'est pas
facile de survivre sur une île
j'adore alésien bien pouvoir nous voit
et on a vu le cateau le bruit du moteur
du cac trouve un peu comme le tambourine
man et elles viennent elles viennent à
côté du 4 août qu'elle tourne autour du
4 août fait incroyable
quand je finissais une année scolaire et
des vides et alors l'île verte a été
ce qui m'a permis de finir
l'enseignement je pense heureux parce
que je venais décompresser ici
[Musique]
notre vie est rythmée par le fleuve déjà
au départ
dans la marée basse on peut pas
traverser ces sexes est presque asséché
complètement d'emmener prisonniers
démarrer
le fait d'être sur une île entourée
d'eau
c'est pas facile d'accès les gens qui
viennent ici c'est des gens qui ont
vraiment envie d'y mener
ce fleuve qui nous enferment nous libère
en même temps et moi le sentiment que
j'ai sur cette île cdh est libre je me
sens libre sur l'île
[Musique]
et
pas fini de monter tous collés dans est
tout seul
mais ça c'est des baux crâne finissent
c'est un beauf ou grises
c'est un gros match c'est une omoplate
de globicéphales presque tous les
mammifères ont des os dans le pénis les
primates aussi sauf l'homme froid y en a
qui pensent qu'ils en ont mais je suis
la vantardise
s'est dit ça date du tome la mer
champlain
[Musique]
une baleine qui pourrit et qui est
enterré dans un dépotoir c'est du
gaspillage mes yeux pourquoi parce que
il ya énormément de musées qui n'ont pas
de squelettes de baleine un pays comme
le québec où il n'y a pas un musée de
sciences naturelles valable dix ans je
parle pas de il ya un petit multi
mesurait de passe à montréal mais ya pas
de vrais musées de sens naturel c'est
comme si la connaissance scientifique ça
ne faisait pas partie de la culture
[Musique]
et le saint laurent pour moi c'est c'est
quelque chose de très important d'abord
c'est un fleuve images d'un fleuve qui
est magnifique et tout simplement
magnifique moi j'ai été moniteur de
plongée pendant une vingtaine d'années
et je l' ai vu ce fleuve dessus et
dessous et je sais que la faune est
extrêmement riche dense alors et c'est
la mère qui rentrent chez nous lé et fo
la [ __ ] et non faut se battre pour
le préserver
pour pouvoir passer le message foot que
les gens est une connaissance
scientifique suffisant même si elle
n'est quand même qu une connaissance de
base mais suffisant pour que le mot
écologie se soit pas un mot comme
support - une émotion quelconque que ça
ça que sa coiffe une réalité une vraie
réalité
[Musique]
en
ici on est dans mon atelier c'est une
pièce où je vis le travail hiver qu'en
été et où je fais des sculptures du beau
matériel avec de l'os avec des bois de
cervidé une fois je l'avais dans les
masses bois de cerf et je suis mon dieu
mais c'est ça pourrait faire une baleine
qui saute
je fais ça je pense à rien du tout cas
ça et c'est un vide tête parce que c'est
pas toujours je ne vis pas une vie
idyllique moi je veux dire j'ai des
problèmes personnels j'ai des problèmes
peu de sortes et j'ai des problèmes de
relations humaines
je suis vieux
quand on est vieux ben on a
on a tous les travers des vieux là qu'il
faut convaincre je suis très conscient
que je suis un vieux bougon d'armement
je veux très conscient que j'ai des
idées qui sont assez arrêté sur
certaines choses mais quand je suis un
peu quand j'ai un peu de vague à l'âme
et tout mais je viens ici puis je règle
mon problème le retrouve
une espèce de paix intérieure
c'est parce que je réussis pas toujours
il ya des fois il ya rien à faire rien à
faire j'essaye bis ça marche pas
[Musique]
si c'est la raison qui rennes le devis
mais qu'on est sensible à l'émotion on a
le meilleur des deux mondes la science
ça sert fournit l'explication mais ça
relève pas de mystère que je sache mois
que le soleil va disparaître dans
quelques milliards d'années qui va faire
une super nova et intérêts c'est pas ça
qui va m'empêcher de profiter d'un
coucher de soleil
la vie c'est c'est l'étincelle qui nous
fait fonctionner et puisque anne
merveilleux c'est qu'on peut la
transmettre je me suis reproduit moi je
me suis prolonger dans le temps et dans
l'espace j'ai un arrière petit fils qui
porte mon chromosome y donc je sais
qu'il ya une partie de mes gènes qui
sont transmis j'ai fait ma job d'animal
[Musique]
j'ai peur pour l'état dans lequel mon
arrière petit fils a trouvé le monde
dans 20 ans à quoi il va ressembler le
monde dans 20 ans je le sais pas moi
mais c'est inquiétant ou alors la
science je vais reprendre le dessus et
là on va régler les problèmes on va se
mettre on va s'atteler les humains parce
qu'on est capable on a tout ce qu'il
faut nous les humains pour sortir de la
misère il ya plein de gens très
intelligents qui instruit mais qui n'ont
pas toujours la capacité à passer leur
message malheureusement mais on a les
moyens de s'en sortir c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire malgré tout
[Musique]
bien
on voit le phare
on est juste en face du segment
moi je suis partie prenante de la nature
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que que
je re que je sois enterré où que je sois
grillé et éventuellement mais atom vont
se retrouver dispersés dans la nature et
puis ils vont être recyclés bon ben ça
va je fais partie du ch partie du
système pour moi c'est une continuité je
suis partie du règne animal du veux
m'intégrer m'intégrer à la terre d'une
façon quelconque éventuellement
donc pourquoi sûr inquiet pourquoi je me
ferais du monde
[Musique]